intel and qualcomm both think that they
can beat apple with their new amazing
apple silicon chips and today we're
gonna talk about not only what has
recently changed but also if this is
actually a possibility the sneaky things
that these companies are doing to try to
make it happen
when they will catch up and defeat apple
and if i think that's a possibility and
why apple is so upset about this let's
start out with intel because this is the
less shady part
starting out apple had a deal with intel
for years using their chips but apple
grew just tired and annoyed about how
slow intel was growing and how much
delays they had so they finally dropped
them and switched over to their own
chips which dominated intel now intel
knew for years the apple was developing
those ships and that it was gonna happen
but what they didn't expect is for
apple's first ships to be this good at
first they just mocked apple for being a
lifestyle brand and then when these
ships came out they started just making
fun of them and putting this crazy ad
campaign going so far as actually hiring
the i'm a mac guy to switch over to
intel side and say that macs aren't real
computers which just blows my mind i
don't know how much money they paid him
and after that 95 mac reported that
intel just like qualcomm said that they
could be apple but that literally lasted
one day because intel's own ceo admitted
the next day that macs are pretty good
and that the apple silicon chips are
ahead of intel's own designs but either
way they are planning to win back
apple's business just showing that intel
was definitely relying on apple so how
is intel going to make this happen
well
meteor lake now at first they thought
that it's gonna take them until
2025 to reach that goal but they've been
making a lot of shifts now the latest
one that just came out because we've had
earnings we've had uh company calls with
a lot more explanation going on now we
know that intel's 12th generation chips
merely made a massive improvement in
performance and they actually did beat
out apple's own chips in a number of
ways even though they used way more
power so that just shows us how good
competition is not only from apple but
also from amd but this chip the meteor
lake that was announced this is the big
deal but now intel basically just
admitted that this is not enough because
at first when they announced it they
were talking about making this chip on a
seven nanometer node designing it by
themselves but it turns out that we just
had an insider leak some information
about this chip
saying that it will actually be made by
tsmc using the same five nanometer node
that apple uses for their m1 chips so
intel is realizing how far ahead apple
is and that they need to step it up and
go further faster to be able to compete
now do i think that intel can compete
with apple i think after this change
it's gonna really help them and this new
style of design of chip that they're
shifting to i think because of apple has
a lot more flexibility we have a tiled
architecture just like apples does we
have hybrid cores that are focusing on
low power better graphics just like
apple has so seeing what they did with
the 12th gen shifts that performance and
now this improvement with this latest
jump that was announced i think they
actually have a pretty good chance but
this is where we need to switch to
qualcomm apple's competitor in the
mobile space qualcomm said that they can
beat apple's m1 chips
thanks to what do you think how are they
going to do that
x apple engineers now this is crazy we
know that in the past qualcomm had a
really hard time competing with apple
going as far as this latest snapdragon 8
gen 1 chip getting a ton of hype but
when it came down to it it was so far
behind apple's a15 chips which
themselves were a bad upgrade from the
a14 we have an extra graphic score which
is the main difference but apple kind of
took a year off to focus on the next
generation because they were so far
ahead and if you look back years before
that where we had the microsoft tablets
come out with chips that are made by
qualcomm to rival apple i mean they were
terrible compared to the ipads to make
this happen they have gerard williams
which was the former lead of the a
series chips and apple is so upset that
they actually sued him because he was
poaching other key engineers from apple
now three of these guys formed their own
company that said that they are
competing with intel and amd not with
apple because obviously they left apple
but the kicker is that qualcomm straight
up bought their company for 1.4 billion
dollars now isn't that just the best way
to get apple engineers without having a
lot of issues having them leave and have
a new company i don't know if that's
exactly what hired but this is crazy now
that is not the only issue that apple is
facing just recently this came out where
apple is accusing another group of
engineers of stealing chip secrets and
they are suing a startup called rivos
for poaching apple's engineers that have
access to secret company information so
when do you think that qualcomm is going
to be competitive and they will beat out
apple
well they are saying by late
2023 their m1 rival will be available
now
this is just crazy because if you guys
been following along you guys know the
apple is set to release the m2 chip very
soon and by the time that this chip is
going to be released and if there's no
extra delays within with chip shortage
you guys know how this is apple could be
on their way or maybe even have released
the m3 series that they are actually
working on right now
and based on the information that we
already know about the m2 chip it's
gonna be much more powerful than the m1
mark german one of apple's most accurate
leakers he's told us what chips are
coming out we already have the m1 pro
and max with the 32 graphic scores as he
predicted and we also have the m2 which
is going to have 9 and 10 graphics cores
now not only that it will be based on
the a16 so we have advantages of using a
newer node and we already know how much
faster that node is because tsmc gave us
all that information that no change
alone gives us an 11 boost up to over
1900 single core score and 8
278 multi-core score but if apple uses
arm v9 which we think they will because
that's where everything is headed then
our performance boost will be even
greater up to 9322
so how is qualcomm gonna be comparing to
that and that's only on the cpu side on
the graphics side based on the second
scenario we're looking at up to 31
700 graphics score for the m2 which is a
huge leap something that's going to be
very hard to beat so personally i have
to say that i think that these companies
even after poaching and changing up
their plans and using apple's five
nanometer tech with tsmc based on tsmc's
fab they are still going to struggle to
keep up with apple you guys let me know
your thoughts down in the comments
section below we're excited though to
have extra competition that helps
everybody it's gonna help push apple as
well so competition is great for
everybody
but we see that these guys are trying
but they're still years behind so thank
you guys for watching click that circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those great videos right over there
that's been max and i'll see you in the
next video
[Music]